So the prefrontal cortex is guiding the
process,
but I think there's one,
while we are discussing screens,
metaphoric screens in different spaces
where where the show is going on or
auditory and tactile and so on.
I think what is interesting is to think
that those spaces,
those performance spaces are separate.
They're extremely sophisticated.
They tend to be in terms of brain
structure,
very,
very modern in evolution.
They tend to have some of the most
sophisticated circuitry.
But take for example,
the visual system.
Our judicial system is an amazing
instrument and of course the visual
system that allows us to perceive right
now something with the fine perception
that I got,
I can have over the depth of the color
and your sweater and so on.
Uh,
all of that is extremely sophisticated,
but then surrounding that,
let's,
let's consider that like an island and
then surrounding that there's an ocean
and that ocean is filled with knowledge
of how different parts,
different components of past perceptions
have been put together in time when they
were occurring.
And so I think that that's an
interesting analogy is the analogy of
strings that pull the puppets are in the
performance spaces and so it's not that
we should privilege the performance
spaces as the thing that matters,
of course that matters very much because
that's where our consciousness,
our consciousness is actually occurring
quote unquote,
but it's occurring.
They're only by the grace of this trains
that are being pulled from the other
space this elsewhere where you have what
I like to call convergence divergence,
which are end of themselves.
I just want to say,
just pause for a second because this
convergence divergence,
um,
this is,
what you're,
you're making a broader category for
parts of the brain that,
that I recognize,
but you are putting it together in a
larger context as I understand,
after reading your book yesterday.
Good.
Okay.
Just,
just to.
I just wanted to give that info.
Your spirit has tremendously anyway,
but.
So yeah,
that's a very interesting because from a
neutral standpoint,
uh,
you could even say that these structures
are in of themselves rather dumb.
It's not that they know anything
consciously.
What they know is that they have a sort
of internal testimony of the
simultaneous occurrence,
occurrence of certain things at a
certain point.
So for example,
if I will,
uh,
tomorrow remember talking to you today,
I will think of a certain words that you
have said,
pretty simple the sentence you just said
about the book,
which I probably will remember,
uh,
in some form and I will remember the
fact that you have this sweater that I
presume is spink,
although I'm not very good with colored
pink.
Okay?
Yes.
Okay.
And the pink and the white shirt and
your beautiful blonde hair.
Uh,
so how do I put this thing together?
This is occurring right now and I am
recording the simultaneity of occurrence
of Your Voice,
of certain ideas and certain
requirements,
but they are in different places.
So we need to find in the brain a place
where signals about all these different
things can come together in,
can make a record of the,
the,
the proximity and simultaneity of this
in time.
Yes.
Temporality.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll go there next.
And once that happens,
once that record is made,
then it is possible to reactivate the
record and to come back into the same
regions where this is happening to us
right now,
and reconstruct something that he's
going to be a paler version of the
original,
but it's going to relate to the
original.
And that,
by the way,
gets us into one very important issue,
which is the issue that you don't have
a,
a facsimile memory of.
It's important.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't have a memory.
I'm not going to have a polaroid
picture.
You right now talking to me.
No soundtrack.
What I'm going to have is all these bits
and pieces of information with which I
will be allowed to reconstruct something
of this moment.
But of course the reconstruction is not
going to be entirely accurate.
And who knows,
maybe that in time I may even make a
confusion and I could be asked the court
to say what you're wearing.
And I could say that you were wearing a
blue eye.
And I think this is,
this is quite
important,
um,
that the fact that our brains and our
memories are not like recording devices
like film,
um,
and that,
that is how we,
some significant errors and those errors
also can be created by an emotion
attached to the experience so that you
can even entirely invert a memory
depending on the motivation in some way.
And I don't mean conscious motivation,
but they deeply embodied a drive or push
sometimes that can have an emotional
valence that will change memory.
Yes.
People,
you know,
the,
the testimonies in court very often
affected.
Yes.
Yeah.
You have all sorts of misattribution
errors in versions of time sequence and
so on.
And that's because we don't have a
filmic medium.
We don't have cellulite with an optic
soundtrack attached to it.
What we have is this incredibly
sophisticated mechanism of transforming
is,
it's almost like coding.
You have this little bits and pieces
that are occurring in time and then you
have the possibility of reconstruction
or react reactivation,
which is very,
very,
very intriguing.
And by the way,
it's extremely economic.
You know,
the,
the brain.
Whenever it can,
um,
does things,
I'm facilely and a leisurely and you
know,
if,
if there's no need to repeat and
reinvent the wheel,
well this is,
this is very important for,
um,
perception because perception,
the way we perceive things has to do
with deep learning in the brain.
And uh,
one of my favorite philosophers who,
you mentioned a footnote in your most
recent book,
Molly's mellow,
pointy,
talks about perception of something he
calls stereotypes.
And in neuroscience there's a similar
idea,
which is that the brain also will take
in information according to its own
expectations.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Because we don't,
you know,
it's not just that we have memory of the
things that we have been living through
since we were born.
We have past memories that we have
inherited a through a whole history of
evolution before us.
That in fact I have memories of things
that our fore runners have been doing
it.
I'm not just talking about the human
four runners,
four runners that go all the way into
reptiles and single cells,
you know,
things that have been done in a certain
way in life,
in life forms,
in that course,
of course,
been memorized by the biological
systems.
We.